big breaking news story ladies and
gentlemen breaking Manhattan grand jury
votes to indict Donald Trump trump will
be the first former president to be
indicted the grand jury's vote regards
an alleged settlement made with adult
film actress Stormy Daniels during the
former president's 2016 campaign
according to five people with knowledge
of the matter per the New York Times
Trump and Dale's allegedly had a sexual
encounter in 2006 according to the claim
Trump is the first former president to
face criminal charges after office while
the specific charges are currently
unknown an indictment is expected to be
announced as Trump will be asked to
surrender and face arraignment a lawyer
for the former president confirmed his
indictment shortly after the initial
announcement the AP reported in a March
18th truth social post Trump said he
would be arrested on the 21st and called
for people to protest and take our
nation back okay so basically after that
they postpone the indictment things get
delayed then a bunch of people who are
you know conservative but not pro-trump
started saying Trump's grifting he's
lying it's not going to happen then
today they announced I think it was
today they announced the grand jury was
going to be suspended for a month and
then all of a sudden just like a couple
hours ago they announced they voted to
indict Donald Trump so obviously my
opinion on this as we've talked about it
before is this is silly and stupid but
while we have you man what do you think
uh I mean if he committed a crime I
think that you should have the book
thrown at him I think generally this is
a misdemeanor crime usually there's a
statute of limitations but
um if records were falsified in an
attempt to cover up another crime then
the statute of limitations is extended
but I don't think any of us have seen
the indictment yet so I wait till they
unseal the indictment to see how silly
stupid I think it is but hey if you
broke the law I think you should have
the book thrown at him I have an
ex-president I don't believe are above
the law so I absolutely agree I'd like
to see more presidents get arrested in
church oh I mean it makes me nervous
guys that's the first time in history a
president's ever been indicted you know
I I agree I don't care if if they break
the law then they should be charged my
issue I suppose is it seems overtly
political I mean how can we say that
without seeing the indictment that's a
fair point but you just said that but it
seems overtly political we don't know
for sure but it seems that way
especially considering the dude
campaigned on investigating Trump they
spent years and this was the best they
could come up with that Cohen paid
Stormy Daniels to not write a book or
give an interview or whatever about
banging Trump and that Trump tried
claiming it was legal fees despite the
fact that a letter was put out 2018
where Cohen Cohen's lawyer said Cohen
paid for it out of pocket was never
reimbursed so I mean like that feels
kind of like exculpatory evidence
outright which makes the scene political
so do you think that the payments to him
that were recorded in a book do you
think that's all fake or I so
I don't know well definitely I'm I'm
interested in seeing what what you know
what the reason I don't understand
because like the thing that drives me
the crazy so how much do they entertain
stuff too where things will come out and
people immediately say this is political
it's partisan it's like why not just
wait till these diamonds come out and
then we can actually see when these
diamonds come out it might be that
there's a lot of stuff in there it's
like oh okay that's fair and it might be
wow this is BS like it's obviously
because Brad campaigned on doing this
sure but I mean like people can campaign
on all sorts of things right Julian a
campaign on Clinton New York the guy
well
if you campaign on like enforcing laws
like is that a political no he's
campaigned on investigating Trump maybe
I thought Trump broke some laws and but
I mean like yeah I mean it seems like a
fair thing to campaign John show me the
man I'll show you the the law that he
broke right well we're about to see that
show and watching a diapers are until so
here's here's what I think with the the
potential of this case you have a lawyer
I imagine you've gone through legal
stuff right um not like a dedicated one
but I've yeah I have a couple depending
on what I'm going through yeah do you go
through their itemized invoices you
might I mean I'm I don't know if you do
or not um I've never made a single
payment of over ten thousand dollars to
a lawyer so usually they send me the
itemized thing and I just they built by
every 15 minutes or 10 minutes or
whatever these bills that Trump's paying
are over hundreds of thousands of
dollars I think for Cohen wasn't it like
330 000 or something at the end of the
day something like that and so
I really doubt Trump was handed this
invoice looked at and said no no we
can't we can't say we paid stormy that's
illegal let's falsify This Record he
probably got a legal bill was like just
pay him I don't know whatever right did
it wasn't the didn't Cohen claim that he
and Trump had personal conversations
about this particular issue yes after
the fact but in 2018 Cohen's lawyer
claimed Cohen paid for it personally
without instruction from Trump and was
never reimbursed for it sure do you
think has Cohen claimed otherwise though
after the fact yes claimed otherwise so
and those times were under uh oath
correct uh then he should be charged
with perjury if that's the case but was
the the statements by his his boss were
those statements under oath his boss
yeah or the other lawyer yeah the other
lawyer were those under oath I'm I don't
know who the letter was filed with so
something that Rosa said that I think
was really important when he was asked
for um questioning this was like three
or four years ago I think is uh he would
get very irritated when he was brought
before Congress and claims of the media
I think Jim Jordan did this to him he
the claims in the media be brought
before him and they'd say well what do
you think about this so what do you
think about that well I don't think
that's true it's like do you think
they're lying and something Rosenstein
said was well if you think they're lying
bring them and have them testify under
oath so I think it's important when we
look at people's statements people say a
lot of things we saw this with Giuliani
and his claims about Trump people say a
lot of things and then when they're
under oath their stories change
significantly so I'd always be cautious
to compare statements made under oath to
something that some guy might have just
said in a letter or said to the press or
said to a friend who's Rosenstein I
think this was sent to the federal uh
Election Commission
the uh maybe yeah that's what it's it
says via email Federal Election
Commission Office of compliance
examination and legal Administration
attention Crystal Dennis and the letter
says that Cohen did it of his own
volition he paid for it out of pocket he
was never reimbursed so I I would put it
this way it seems political when you
have a letter like this from years ago
from five years ago and but but again
fair point we'll see what happens my my
issue with it for the most part is
really
falsified record misdemeanor charge we
you want to get into the debate about
Barack Obama blowing up a kid because I
I would absolutely love to talk about
that uh look if they want to give Trump
a misdemeanor charge and slap and lock
them up for however many months a
misdemeanor gets them I would absolutely
be willing to make that to a great
you're right he's got to be charged next
up Obama he blew up a kid a bunch of
kids I don't know if Obama broke a law
I think I don't think Americans of any
capacity are allowed to kill other
Americans of any capacity don't cops do
it all the time not like I mean it seems
like they in the service a little bit of
a semantic trick you played there right
okay
obviously you can kill people in
self-defense but Obama bombed a civilian
restaurant in Yemen a country we're not
at war with killing civilians including
a 16 year old American citizen like you
can't if you're in the military you
can't just or a cop you can't just go
and kill somebody murder you can't
murder yeah but I imagine the
justification Obama would use was that
this was in defense of U.S interests or
defense of the United States and in his
role as commander-in-chief the president
of the United States has offered why
deference from the Supreme Court for
taking actions in the commission of
protecting the United States even if we
disagree with them
yeah I think that's criminal I mean
that's fine but there's a question of
like is it illegal versus do you think
it's criminal like bad right it's
probably bad I guess but like so so the
the Obama administration's argument was
that they were trying to Target a
terrorist leader but I'm not I mean you
make a fair point but I'd be willing to
argue that the president does not have
the authority to bomb countries we are
not at war with well what about when
Trump assassinated suleimani that was an
assassination where was that taking
place in Iraq in Iraq yeah a country we
have an AUM F over an authorization for
use of military force I don't think the
authorization for use of military force
I'm pretty sure we were on good terms of
the regular point I don't know if we had
the ability to do whatever we wanted in
that country that was a political
assassination though our executive
orders that are against the United
States I don't disagree sure I'm just
saying that in general there's multiple
questions going on here we can say do we
um do we think it's wrong or bad
probably I think generally the United
States uh president Killing American
citizens is generally a Bad Thing unless
it's really good justification for it
but the difference between that versus
is it illegal and I think that the law
tends to we argue about this a little
bit before the show when Trump was doing
things at the border that we thought
when I say we progressives and the left
got really mad at the Supreme Court tend
to decide with him because the president
has given why deference over matters
what was the address
um I think it was when he was using um
he couldn't get the funding for the
border wall
um oh no no it was over Banning certain
people coming into the country
um when he he named the there were seven
Muslim majority countries and when he
was running for president even Giuliani
said he's trying to find ways to do a
Muslim majority ban technically he's not
allowed to Venezuela North Korea on that
list though yeah well he changed it up I
think after the first one got or didn't
go through for whatever reason but once
he did that ban when people tried to
challenge it the Supreme Court basically
said ah president border he could do
almost anything he wants because it's
the president yeah but that's not
blowing up a kid I didn't say it was
blowing up a kid but I've been saying
that in general you would think that
like we're talking like border uh if
we're talking about like passing policy
at the border that seems like a
congressional thing like we should be
passing laws about immigration but the
president can do that basically all on
his own because the Supreme Court's like
he's the president National Security he
can do almost whatever he wants I think
I think I think I think I think I see
the disconnect
I'm I'm less concerned with legality
okay I'm only talking legalities right
so I think that a President Who bombs a
country we're not at war with should be
stripped of his power and criminally
charged for killing an American citizen
and it should be literally under the U.S
murder statutes that are covered by
multiple state and federal laws
I don't I I don't look at it like well
you know is it murder statue could I in
Tennessee get arrested if I bomb
somebody in Yemen is that a I don't know
what the I mean that's a good point you
might yeah absolutely I mean that might
be like way worse than murder it might
be terroristic International uh there
might like I'm pretty sure if you as an
American citizen set up a bomb in a
foreign country you'd be criminally
charged in the US
state statutes right that sounds like
Federal International Federal yeah maybe
Julian Assange is being criminally
charged in the U.S even though he's not
a U.S citizen who didn't do anything in
the United States kim.com for that
matter too I mean the dudes never even
been that was never this country and
they went after him so I just think that
when we I think it's really important
that we separate conversations of what
should somebody be charged with versus
like what do we think is wrong and I
think both conversations are important
we could talk about like is this wrong
or is it not wrong and there's probably
a good conversation we had there but
there's a difference between that versus
like somebody needs to be charged here
because like charged with what is there
actually a crime broken or is it just
like we're really upset about this
particular thing which is fair yeah I
think the Patriot acts insane and the
National Defense authorization act
insane it gives them the uh I mean it
really gives gives the president the
authority to bomb an American citizen
anywhere it doesn't it gives them the
right to rendition anyone anywhere in
the world and then hold secret tribunals
and I think that's wrong and I think if
we're gonna just play like the question
of is it legal well then there's a whole
lot of really awful stuff the
government's gonna end up doing if we
just say well they made it legal so they
can do it but yeah but this is what I
always fight against like when it comes
to like BLM and everything too
um it's important to change the law so
we want people to be held accountable we
have to change the laws to reflect what
we think our moral will is so that we
can actually get people to be held
accountable and because otherwise you
just get a bunch of people like this is
wrong do something it's like okay well I
don't know what you want us to do like
it's not illegal like we can't do
anything about it you know if we changed
the law and it made it illegal to bomb
kids in Yemen then we wouldn't be able
to charge people that were doing it
while it was legal because it was legal
when they read it yeah probably but I
mean do we want to make it so that when
we change laws we can retroactively
right I don't anyway like I don't we're
probably I don't think we're ever
officially at war with Syria right no
but Trump bombed the airport is that
like but again he's the president it's
our military like I guess the other
question is is you know in talking about
Abdul Rahman al-alaki he wasn't the
intended target the intended target was
somebody else and he and he had just a
few weeks prior killed Anwar al-alaki
Abdul rahman's dad so he kills this guy
who's an American citizen then argues
well look you know he was a Jihadi he
was preaching against the United States
he had to be stopped but then a few
weeks later he targets a civilian
restaurant in Yemen blows up this
restaurant with a drone strike killing a
sick killing Anwar al-lucky's son
abdulrahman and the response was well we
were targeting a tear leader so it's
okay so I guess the question is
I'm curious as to the legalities and the
moral standing of one does the president
have the legal authority to kill anyone
in any country at any time in the eyes
of the United States
if he does and hits the wrong target and
kills an innocent American citizen is
there a manslaughter similar charge for
this kind of conflict I think
internationally uh unfortunately I think
we just don't tend to hold countries
responsible
um this has happened multiple times I'll
avoid the USS Liberty example because
that's a whole loaded thing but uh there
was let's see I think Iran after we
killed suleimani in the night or the
night after that followed Iran
accidentally shot down I think one of
their own civilian airliners and there
were no charges nothing was held for
that I believe in Iran in Iran yeah and
they're like authoritarian though you
know true no I'm just saying but
internationally um I believe it happened
over Ukraine as well I think that there
was a missile launched from Crimea I
believe that was probably with the
assistance of Russian troops there was a
civilian airliner shot down there that
nothing happened the United States I
believe
um I think we shut down a civilian plane
that killed like over 150 over 200
people that might have been south of
Iran I think
um flying towards Saudi Arabia maybe and
then we didn't do anything about that we
said sorry but I think that was like 200
or so when he said I mean it happens it
sucks but I mean press it and
internationally is that like sometimes
mistakes happen countries do mistakes
they're bad and you pay money sometimes
but there's usually not like Criminal
Courts for those types of mistakes but
it was proven then yeah of course we say
um you know the best I could do on short
notice the ACL ACL you wrote an article
saying that it was unlawful
well if the ACLU said it no I mean yeah
it's it's when they said which was
unlawful the the not just the killing of
Abdul Abdullahi but the other civilians
that were killed in these in these
countries went out of war with was it
says the killing program isn't only
unlawful it's unwise and that's about
you know on the short term there have
been legal arguments made that Obama
does have the right to kill Americans
abroad but I kind of feel like you know
we've got multiple amendments that
afford American citizens a plethora of
Rights before they can just kill you so
that's where that's where I'm at on the
issue I suppose thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time